105 103 the final score if you're if
you're just joining us
here let's take a look at the highlights
and then we can talk after the
highlights you got to feel bad for the
joker man
that kid tried to will his team to win
this game
you know and uh early on lebron was
lebron and you know he just took over
the game and kept him in it kept him up
he scored their first 12 points oh i
didn't even realize that i thought it
was 16.
but uh he was just you know all over the
floor offensively
and that really set the tone for the
game it down
so they when denver made that run it was
they weren't up
big he had 20 points in the first half
did lebron on eight of 11 shooting and
three out of four from deep
more good laker defense
oh my three sons
[Laughter]
uh that's a reference only ernie got oh
i heard it all my life growing up hey
how's [ __ ] how's robbie
that's uncle charlie
we didn't watch that we watched good
times
[Laughter]
everybody had a thing for them all right
yeah a little finger roll by caruso
alona
60 to 50 going to the third quarter
let's watch the nuggets chip away in
this one kenny oh yes they you know
trip away i think they just got off into
the aggressive and joker went back to
the post they had
got got the mismatches on on on uh here
you have caruso guard him on those
pick-and-rolls
and then you're gonna find your shooters
see i love what denver's put him in the
post when you put him out there on the
top
he's not nearly as effective and michael
porter jr had a good game as long as
as well as pj dose if he makes his free
throws oh my god
this might be great yeah no doubt yeah
oh look at that
great effort sorry mr fritos he gave
great effort and great energy
yeah they got some young talent man
lakers 84 82
and then it's jamal murray
oh how again was that beautiful 87-86
great pass by rondo here fumbled for a
second and then casey
oh he drains it and linka's got a very
bad habit of running the shot clock down
that's a tough set right there
oh we're gonna see that one again too
america with the stakes a little higher
so they're up by eight and then the
joker goes
on a one-man wrecking crew good shot
11 straight points and he finally hit a
three-pointer for the first time in
three games
for three oh man i just feel bad for
joker because that was he was trying to
will his team to this victory
they all played well they played well
that was that was a good game
he was not going to let them lose
tonight but
this is great right here that tip right
there to give him the lead
to 101-100 let us say you always got to
have your hands up
too little ron let's tell you how smart
he is too he knew the shot clock was
running down
but here comes davis with the answer
and the lakers are up one like he had a
youth scorer scored mentality right
there
this is like he said he let him get to
his strong hand
kill him like roberta flack said
one point game killing me softly like
roberta fletcher yeah
wide open three for caruso comes up
short and then
you've got murray with the block you got
to get it though you got to get that
rebound
if you get that first rebound because
the block gives you two points
and there is anthony davis well you
gotta follow him yeah there was no
screen probably you gotta feel
that ain't no screen yeah that was a
magnet
man first buzzer beater for a.d
in about five seasons tell you what get
joe even joker on that play man that's
how great of a kid
he is that wasn't he miss manning he
tried to get a hand up
[Music]
that's just better offers man shake a
guy's hand that's a hell of a shot
yeah but you got to get through that
pitch yeah there's no pick there was
actually no pick i think you're looking
for lebron to
set the pick so you could switch if you
were plumley but there was no pick set
by lebron
so there's no switch the lakers 105
103. davis goes for 31 his fifth
30-point game of these playoffs lebron
goes for 26 after having 20 in the first
half
continuous contavious caldwell pope had
11 and the lakers win it 105
to 103. here's frank vogel
in um you can only call lava shot
now right there okay i'm going to tell
them
to do this basketball team let's keep
our head down focus on the work one step
at the top
and this one if you're denver really
stings when you come back like that and
the game is right there
and then they break your heart at the
horn chuckster listen man
uh that's one of the best games i've
seen
the denver nuggets you know we keep
saying they got our respect
and that man that joker 11 straight
points he was trying to
will his team to a win and i got nothing
but respect
for those nuggets oh man this is going
to be tough to come back from
uh but i'm not kenny what the hell was
plumley
thinking yeah well it switched
everything and he no but he never
thought but he thought lebron is going
to be sitting but lebron wasn't
the big all you have to do is just keep
going and it would have made it a much
more difficult shot lebron would have
had to make the
the shot because then lebron would have
been open over the top
so he would have been open over the top
so what it was is anthony davis running
if you're freezing because you freeze
your head you no no he granted
he can't see you so what they wanted was
anthony davis to come over and just
throw it over
the top to lebron and so he could have
an easy shot
or shoot over it but he didn't have to
because this guy was
wide open like wide open yeah like right
here you're screaming switch there's no
pick set on you brother yeah
i'm gonna give a.d a lot of credit
that's just a hell of a shot but man
plumley cannot let that happen you gotta
chase that guy over
and it's hard to you know pinpoint one
single incident but
the fellows are right like you know you
there's certain rules switch
everything but there's certain rules
when certain things apply if lebron is
setting a screen then you switch you
can't call a switch early first of all
you got to be
up next to anthony davis don't give him
space he gave him space then he tried to
call
call a switch and like kenny said uh
grant couldn't see
and the man had a wide open shot like
you said he didn't follow
a.d he ran right to lebron right to
lebron and he was looking
you know he was in the game he said well
why did palmer come back in the game
because
you were thinking they're going to throw
a lob you'll say okay so we're going to
negate this lob stuff
we're going to put joker on the ball and
put plumley in the middle
and it's going to and then they said no
you forget anthony davis could play
on the outside too yeah like he's not a
inside player he's a perimeter player
too
and then they ran a play that put him on
the perimeter and really confused
plumley
and brought him into rarefied air you
know it's like it's like a swimmer he
was he was in water too deep he just
can't swim out there
he doesn't know what he's yeah and you
know like i say uh anthony davis made a
hell of a shot congratulations to the
lakers man but
i i just got to take my head off to that
joker man i hope america is getting a
chance
to see how great a player this kid is i
mean
to single-handedly score 11 straight
points and will your team
and he listen he's going like he he had
great assists
he take on all like afternoon says he
takes the all-defensive first team guy
down on the post and says
we need a basket i'm going to take
anthony davis as great as you are i'm
going to take you in the post
and roberta flack yes really softly 30
points
for a yoke